get out the car come to me stay in the
car stay in the car hey what'd you say
about that Genesis was that car with
these guys
oh she identified him
yeah they they just went through the
wood line and went down there I scanned
this with thermal
just in case they were dumb enough to
actually stay here
I didn't see anything
but neither of the cars are code code
19. oh I have no
well she was passenger then she's yeah
they already went all the way through
got a ride and came back
get out the car
get out the car
get out the car
yo get out the car come to me stay in
the car stay in the car come to me I got
you got you hey go go ready go ready got
you I until 62 can you advise
turn off the vehicle
yo get out the car
yeah
[Music]
get off the car yo
get out the tell him to get out the car
get out of the car tell him to get out
the car you stay in tell him to get out
the car tell him to get out the car
tell him to get out the car nothing's
gonna happen nothing's gonna happen get
out the car
nothing's gonna happen
nothing's gonna happen just get out the
car tell him to get out the car look
tell him to get out the car please get
out the car tell him to get out the car
get out the car
get out of the park
that's it
I don't know
what you doing
um
the good
please
I have nothing to do with nothing ain't
nothing in the car
can I call my people bro
[Music]
[Music]
right now
what's your name
I'm right here